ah the northern cape province is known
for its wide open spaces mining cattle
and sheep farming shadrach hora de Tata
has been raising cattle at berm class
for close to 40 years and says the dry
conditions and low rainfall in the past
five is the worst he's ever seen he's
spending $1,000 a week on feed for his
cattle because they have nowhere to
graze on the parched land by
Yubikey it's very very difficult we've
had very little rain since 2017 this
year we've had nothing at all
I'm selling my cows because of the
drought and I've saved nothing he sells
his cattle at a local auction which are
more frequent these days as farmers get
rid of livestock that are a drain on
their finances but the market is flooded
and livestock prices are low another
farmer says trying to survive the
drought is almost impossible if the
rains don't come it puts pressure on us
because we can't farm and can't provide
jobs the knock-on effect is that people
don't have money to spend in town
businesses are suffering because no one
is buying anything the farming lobby
group Agrio say says at least 60,000
agricultural workers in three provinces
have lost their jobs and the industries
lost millions of dollars the government
is providing some relief to farmers
battling the drought it's spending 2
million dollars to buy and distribute
fodder to farmers to feed their animals
but this is a short-term plan and many
say it's not enough water restrictions
are being enforced in cities across
South Africa for the first time in years
the water level in the Valle dam which
supplies Johannesburg and the capital
Pretoria has fallen to just under half
full
that's especially critical because of
Africans use 320 liters of water
everyday the global average is about a
hundred and seventy liters the situation
is very serious however it is not one
that calls for
panic it is under control the reliable
supply of water at an acceptable
quantity and quality is essential for
the future development of South Africa
the government is expected to announce
new water conservation plans and how
it's going to improve supply
infrastructure but the concern to ensure
taps don't run dry is clear with the
government calling restrictions on water
use the new normal family mela al
jazeera northern cape province south
africa